il s'en est passé des choses en deux ans
après notre tour des amériques
on a repris nos bonnes habitudes f
l'idée venue mais au tgv il va enfin à
s'arrêter
jeff regarde le tgv passera par boussole
les tuche j'ai décidé de me présenter à
l'élection présidentielle
ah c'est une bonne décision mondiale
mais tu ton là tout d'abord dompter josh
et pourquoi que c'est mon or c'est tout
sans débours points c'est beaucoup
tassé n'aime pas ce à dire que sur cette
france est là ça qui va être pour toi
jeff tuche quel est votre programme
qui d'entre eux koh lanta iso voice on
aura vraiment tout vu bichon jeff tuche
de candidats que personne n'attendait
élu avec 57 % des voix
pourquoi moi je vous dis je vais voter
pour vous déclaration ses problèmes ses
patins bon courage au nouveau président
non aux français voilà les cuisines de
l'elysée à la cuisine tabata prévoit son
sens moral
samurai c'est la mayonnaise qui piquent
qui piquent et puis tellement frotte les
yeux qui piquent samouraï non ça va
aller ça valait
[Musique]
et je tu auras le leader cégétiste la
loi tuchel vous permettra de bénéficier
d'un jour férié
avant le jour férié pour vous préparer
et d'un jour férié
après le jour férié pour vous remettre
du jour férié il suffisait d'y penser
rester assis rester assis pendant que
j'y pense là vous pourrez un peu
débarrasser votre truc là parce que moi
j'ai pas huit bras je suis pas un pool
[Musique]